this is a production of Cornell
University
hello everybody for those of you who
don't know me my name is Kiera Crowley
is not just introduced me and I spent
the last two years working in Matt
sustainable copying systems lab and my
research has focused on the cereal rye
as a cover crop and the effects of
different management strategies on soil
health weed suppression soybean yield
and profitability so I'm going to be
presenting to you some of my results
today and I'm it really excited to be up
here after these two years and two
seasons of field work and finally at
this point presenting mistake so um I
wanted to before I get started I just
want to thank a dr. harold venice and
dr. Miguel Gomez on for being on my
committee as well so i'm going to start
just with a brief introduction to my
research and then i'm going to focus on
the results as of 2016 there were three
hundred and thirty thousand acres of
soybean planted in new york state that's
two and a half times the acreage in two
thousand so soybean production is a
large and growing industry in New York
State in addition as of 2014 New York
rake to number three in the country in
terms of number of organic farms so
organic production is also a large and
growing industry in New York State
however as I'm sure many of you are
aware of there are many challenges with
organic production and perhaps the main
challenge is with weed suppression so
typically in organic systems the main
tool for managing weeds is tillage
however reliance on village can lead to
problems as we all know it can destroy
soil structure which can lead to erosion
and compaction it's also quite fuel and
labor intensive so that is presented
challenge the third challenge I'd like
to talk about is not only a challenge to
organic production but to all
agricultural production and that's
increased climate variability what
you're seeing in this map is that
between nineteen fifty eight and 2012
the amount of precipitation falling
during heavy rainfall events increased
71 percent in the Northeast region so
we're seeing more intense storms
we're also seeing more drought like we
experienced last summer so how are we
going to deal with all of these
challenges well one possible solution is
planting cover crops and that's really
what our focus is on and it's exciting
solution that a lot of farmers and
researchers are interested in it has
potential to improve soil health and
weed suppression and perhaps even
increase profitability and so my
research is really focused on cereal rye
as a cover crop and assessing the extent
to which it can address some of these
challenges so why cereal rye well cereal
rye is a really great cover crop for
several reasons one is that it's
feasible for a late fall planting so
that's really important especially in
the Northeast we're harvesting is
typically later and you really need to
get a cover crop established and going
before the winter comes cereal rye also
reduces winter soil erosion it produces
a large amount of biomass so it is good
at suppressing weeds and it can also be
used as a forage which we'll talk a
little bit more about so there are three
different management methods of cereal
rye that we were really interested in
looking at the first is involved
incorporating the cereal rye at jointing
stage and we call this the plow down
treatment then we had a wry llege
treatment where the cereal rye was
harvested at boot stage and the stubble
was incorporated and then finally we
have a plow down treatment where the
cereal rye was roller crimps and laid on
the soil surface to remain there
throughout the season as a weed
suppressive mulch and I'll show you a
short clip of a roller crimper in a
second in case you haven't seen one
before but these three treatments were
compared to a no cover crop treatment
and we were especially interested in the
Rye llege and roll down treatments the
Rye llege because of its because of his
growing interest from farmers in
harvesting their cover crops to increase
profitability and the roll down because
of its ability to suppress weeds and
therefore allow no-till during the
soybean season in an organic production
so in case some of you haven't seen a
roller crimper this is the roller
crimper rolling down the cereal rye in
my experiment in 2016
so as you can see this cylinder is
literally rolling the ride down and
crimping it to terminate it so that it
will not come back as a weed and it will
stay on the soil surface and as a weed
suppressive mulch so our hypothesis was
that compared to a no cover crop control
integrating a cereal rye cover crop
prior to organic soy bean would improve
soil health weed suppression soybean
yield and profitability just to give a
brief outline of our materials and
methods the experiment was initiated in
2014 and repeated in 2015 it was set up
as a randomized complete block design
with four replicates cereal rye was
drilled at a hundred and eighty eight
kilograms per hectare in the fall and
the soybean was planted at six hundred
and eighteen thousand seeds per hectare
data was analyzed with linear
mixed-effects models so the fixed
effects were treatment year and a
treatment by your interaction and the
random effects were a block and blocked
by your interaction and then we compared
the ls means with tukey's hsd so data
collection included cover crop biomass
soil sampling Cornell soil health
analyses including soil respiration
potentially mineralized will not risen
wet aggregate stability and active
carbon water infiltration which we
measured with Cornell sprinkle
infiltrometer zeeeee which I'll show you
in a minute soil moisture soil
temperature weed biomass grain yield and
finally I conducted an economic analysis
where I looked at the variable costs the
labor required and the return over
variable costs for each of these
treatments so this is the Cornell
sprinkle infiltrometer for those of you
who haven't seen it it was designed by
dr. Hale Venice and Bob Jindal Beck and
it is used to apply a constant rainfall
rate to the soil surface and so what we
the indicator that we calculate from
that is sorptive ax t which takes into
account both the time to run off TR 0
and our the rainfall
rate and so you're able to compare how
long it takes to run off in each
treatment where you do this measurement
so before i get into the results i just
wanted to remind you about the weather
in the last couple of years this is the
blue line is the 30-year average of
accumulated precipitation between april
and october the red line is 2015 and the
Green Line is 2016 as you can see 2015
15 was an abnormally wet year and 2016
was abnormally dry and it's especially
important to note this flat line here in
June and throughout a lot of July where
we were really getting no rain at all
and that really did affect our results
looking at cereal rye biomass there was
no treatment by your interaction here
but I did include bars for years within
the treatment just because I wanted to
show you that there was a year effects
there was more cereal rye biomass in
2016 and in 2015 and this is simply
because the cereal rye was seated
earlier it was seated in September on
September 18th in that second year
whereas it was seated on October seventh
the year before that so we did have more
cereal rye biomass the second year but
what's more important to note here is
the treatment differences so these
letters indicate differences pulled over
years so we're seeing that the roll-down
had a higher cereal rye biomass than the
other two treatments and this is simply
because it was in the ground growing for
longer like two to three weeks longer so
there was significantly more biomass
there that was rolled down getting into
some of the soil health results as I
said I did several soil health tests
however there were no treatment
differences with wet aggregate stability
or active carbon and don't really have
time today to get into the potentially
mineralize obligin results so I'm going
to present the soil respiration results
and soil respiration is really a measure
of how much co2 is evolved during a
certain time period so it's measuring
microbial activity
and we did see a higher soil respiration
in the roll down treatment compared to
the no cover treatment and this can be
explained by the fact that there was
more biomass in that treatment the
cereal rye was growing for a long time
the roots were developed and it makes
sense that there'd be more microbial
activity in that treatment than in the
no cover where there was no cereal rye
looking at syrup tivity just to remind
you that this was a indicator that was
calculated by using the cornell sprinkle
infiltrometer so we're measuring the
time to run off and we are seeing that
in the roll-down treatment on the time
to run off was longer than in the no
cover treatment and again this makes
sense as the water is dripping from the
infiltrometer in the roll-down treatment
that cereal rye is absorbing a lot of
that water and also slowing down the the
water going to the soil surface giving
it more time to infiltrate in addition
there's macro pores that the cereal rye
roots have created growing in that soil
so that also facilitates infiltration so
it makes sense that there would be a
longer time to run off in the rolled on
treatment compared to the no cover
moving on to soil moisture this is soil
moisture in 2015 in 2015 we started
measuring at the beginning of August and
as you can see so the the stars here are
to signify that the roll-down treatment
had a mean that was significantly
different than the other three
treatments so we're seeing that the
roll-down treatment on these four dates
was had significantly higher soil
moisture than all of the other
treatments and this can be explained by
the cereal rye slowing down evaporation
and also enhancing water infiltration as
we saw with the circ tivity and we saw
this trend again in 2016 this time I
knew what I was doing a little bit
better and started measuring earlier in
the season so I started measuring soil
moisture may thirty first when we
planted the soybeans and we saw higher
again higher soil moisture in the rolled
on treatment compared to all the other
treatments on on many of the dates
measured and this has been seen in the
literature it as I said it makes sense
float evaporation and improved
infiltration looking at soil temperature
I'm going to only prevent soil
temperature data from 2016 because again
we only started collecting data in 2015
in August and there were no differences
between treatments but in 2016 we did
see differences between treatments when
we looked at weekly average and maximum
temperatures so as you can see here
again the Stars indicating when the
roll-down was had a significantly
different mean compared to the other
three treatments and this time a lower
mean so you can see that the roll down
on several of the dates had a lower
average and lower maximum weekly
temperature compared to the other
treatments and this is simply because of
the insulated effects of the cereal rye
so it's blocking that solar radiation
and also reflecting it so the lower soil
temperatures have been seen in other
literature and could be a bad thing
earlier in the season when soybeans are
just germinating and starting to grow
but it could also be a good thing later
in the season when soybeans in tilled
treatments have higher soil temperature
and might be experiencing heat stress
and in this treatment they're really
protected from that moving on to weed
biomass we did see higher weed biomass
in the rolled on treatment compared to
the other treatments however it was
still relatively low for organic systems
it was just 400 kilograms per hectare so
that was very low for an organic system
before i get into the yield data i just
wanted to show you some pictures to
compare um as you can see there aren't
really any noticeable differences
between treatments in this year in this
2015 however in 2016 there were some no
default noticeable differences you can
see the soybeans in the roll-down
treatment
we're pretty far behind the other
treatments and this was reflected in the
data in 2015 all of the three cereal
right treatments that saw down the
Rileys that roll down performed well
compared to the no cover treatment
however in 2016 the yield in the rolled
on treatment really dropped off it's
important to note though that in 2015
the yield and when the temperate when
the excuse me when the climate was more
normal when there was more rain the
rolled on treatment did perform very
well compared to the no cover treatments
so but the drop in yield in the drought
year can really be explained by a couple
things one is problems with seed
placement so this is a seed that's on
top of cereal rye that's been pushed
into the row and this has been seen as a
problem enrolled systems but typically
in a normal year it's not a big issue
because the seed does get rainwater and
is able to imbibe and send down those
roots but in a dry year it doesn't we
didn't get any rain after planting and
it wasn't able to imbibe and send down
those roots so this did affect yield and
finally moving on to the economic
analysis I looked at total costs and
total labor by looking at all of the
field operations that occurred in each
treatment so these are all of the field
operations in 2014 and 2015 they're
similar to the field operations occurred
in the second year the only difference
is this year we had I mean in 2015 there
were five intero cultivation events
whereas in 2016 with the dry weather
there weren't as many weeds so not as
much need to cultivate so there were
fewer cultivation events on but in order
to calculate the total cost we took the
custom rates for all of these operations
and then we also added the cost of the
cereal rye seed and the soybean seed to
calculate the total variable costs and
as you can see the no cover treatment
had the the lowest
and that's because there was no cereal
rye being drilled in that treatment so
they avoided that expense on the
roll-down treatment is also a pretty low
cost so that's showing that the lack of
cultivation that's money saved from not
cultivating in that treatment with
almost enough to compensate for that for
the cereal rye and then looking at the
labor this is really really interesting
is the low labor in the roll-down
treatment and that is because again of
the lack of cultivation and so you're
saving a lot of labour time in that
treatment by not doing that cultivation
so not only compared to the no cover is
it lower labor but also compared to the
plow down which might be a more typical
way of managing cereal rye in organic
systems it is much lower labor moving on
to the return over variable costs the
rye llege performed very well although
it had higher cost as we saw in the past
slide mainly because of the harvesting
and baling expenses on you're getting a
lot of added income from that rye llege
sol it did have higher profitability
than the other two cereal right
treatments in both years and even higher
profitability than the no cover
treatment in 2015 and then in in the
roll-down treatment in 2015 we saw that
the profitability was comparable to the
no cover and the roll down and the plow
down however in 2016 the profitability
dropped and again that was because of
the yield drop so in conclusion compared
to the no cover treatment there was
greater soil respiration in the roll
down treatment there was greater
infiltration and soil moisture in the
rolled on treatment compared to the
other treatments weed biomass with
greater in the roll down treatment but
again very reasonable for an organic
really very pretty low the yield was
very low in the roll down treatment in
the drought year in 2016 however it's
important to note that it was also very
good in 2015 when we had more rain and
that's more of a typical year for us so
so it was important to learn that it
doesn't do well in drought but it also
does well in it does do well when there
is more moisture more rain the costs
were lowest in the no cover treatment
but the labor requirement was lowest in
the roll down treatment and finally
profitability with greater in the Rileys
treatment than other cereal right
treatments in both of the years so
overall in summary there is no one
cereal rye management method that gives
you all of the benefits the soil health
the weed suppression the soybean yield
the profitability on certain ones give
you a smattering of benefits you see the
Rileys you're getting increased
profitability with the roll-down you're
getting some increases in soil health
and also reduction in labor which is
very important and you are as I said
also having comparable yields and
comparable profitability in that rolled
on treatment in a good year and so the
rolled on treatment is really getting
pretty close to hitting a lot of those
benefits but good to note that it
doesn't work so well in a drought year
finally I would like to thank all
everybody that helps me in this um I was
really worried I was going to forget
somebody and I think I did well so um
the Cornell nutrient analysis lab
Tatiana and Alejandro and Shelley thank
you all for your help and I'd also like
to thank the USD orgy program for
funding this research the sustainable
cropping systems lab all of our present
and past members all of the research
assistants that helped with the field
work
and finally the Cornell soil health lab
for helping me with all those analyses
and then Paul Zukowski out at musgrave
research farm and all of his team for
helping with the field work thank you
and I think any questions I think will
eliminate the questions you I just
wanted okay yes Chuck I was wondering
about the weed biomass yeah that was an
average over the two years because there
was no treatment by your interaction
there was more weed biomass in the first
year because there was more more
moisture but it wasn't significant yes
and fighters go ahead and write is there
any way to them over that ordeal that a
Republican that situation with all the
investors yeah language
yeah I don't know about a mechanical way
I think that irrigation could work we
tried irrigating but we didn't have the
resources we weren't really set up to
irrigate so we were only able to add
like a quarter inch of rain but if you
were really set up for that than that
might that would help for sure I don't
know about a mechanical way did you have
a good word should we I guess so much to
require in the critical thing like yes
Yeah Yeah right yeah yeah I agree all
right okay okay this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu